Why can't "The Batman" star Robert Pattinson
stand to see certain fish dishes anymore?
And was he serious when he said he wasn't
working out in lockdown?
Keep watching for the details of his regimen.
Batman has been played in a variety of ways
over the years by a wide array of actors,
from Michael Keaton to Christian Bale to Ben
Affleck.
Then there's the latest to don the batsuit,
Robert Pattinson.
Though some seem to have done more than others
before putting on the cape and cowl, there's
no doubt that every Batman actor had to put
in some work to get in shape before taking
on the role.
The physical standards for a Batman actor
change from project to project.
If anything, it's become more integral than
ever recently, with every Batman now guaranteed
at least one or two shirtless scenes displaying
Bruce Wayne's obsession with remaining vigilant
in mastering his body and mind to weed out
Gotham's criminal underbelly.
For "The Batman," pressure was on for the
typically lean Pattinson to bulk up a bit.
He has revealed that he took some fairly drastic
measures to get in shape for the iconic role.
In an interview with People magazine, Pattinson
revealed he was on a strict diet that helped
him physically prepare for the role in only
three months.
And before shirtless scenes, it got really
extreme.
He said:
"You just cut down and cut down and cut down
before the couple of scenes with your shirt
off, and you're counting sips of water."
According to Muscle and Fitness, cutting back
to just sips of water is a strategy that can
be used by bodybuilders and wrestlers trying
to drop weight to make a certain weight class.
The 35-year-old Pattinson said "shame" was
his biggest motivator in building his Batman
body, and he was working out before and after
work.
The actor has said his diet was bland too,
with the sight of boiled fish, a key component
of his diet, causing him discomfort today.
He told On Demand Entertainment,
"I never want to see--"
"Salad?"
"--a piece of white fish with just lemon on
it.
Boiled fish."
Pattinson also had to undergo some fairly
intense physical training.
The actor said his routine included weight
training, boxing drills, military sandbag
drills, and three to six mile runs.
He said,
"It's all about pushing boundaries and building
up to a point where you know you can do justice
to the physicality required."
The actor added that he drew inspiration from
Marvel stars like Robert Downey Jr. and Chris
Hemsworth.
Pattinson's scheduled training included cardio
to start and then a succession of exercises
that sound fun to nobody, like bicycle crunches
and dumbbell side-bends.
The physical commitment from Pattinson is
all the more impressive when you consider
how much he hated exercise before the role,
as he's admitted it would have taken a lot
to get him to do some cardio before "The Batman"
came along.
He joked,
"A few years ago, I would have run a mile
from anything with a physical edge."
"Training's a lot more fun…it's a lot more
fun when you kind of get good at it."
The actor appears to think it was all worth
it — and not just because the film seems
to be doing well with audiences and critics.
He told People that wearing the batsuit on
set was like "wearing a crown or something,"
adding,
"People react to you differently, the crew
reacts differently.
Your entire world suddenly changes."
Pattinson said fitting into the costume, which
he claimed has an "elemental power to it,"
ended up being an essential part of being
able to buy into the role and accept himself
in it.
He explained,
"It's funny, because you read the script and
you spend loads of time trying to figure out,
'How can I play this character who does these
sort of audacious acts?"
His extensive workout routine and respect
for the Batman myth may come as a comfort
to some fans, as the actor has previously
commented about not working out before "The
Batman," which had some thinking he was not
doing enough to prep for the iconic role.
While "The Batman" production was halted due
to the COVID-19 pandemic, Pattinson said that
working out was not a "high priority" for
him, and those working out in quarantine were
"part of the problem."
But Pattinson told MovieMaker his earlier
comments were all in jest.
Of course he was staying in shape for the
role.
He said,
"You're playing Batman.
You have to work out.
I think I was doing the interview when I was
in lockdown, as well, in England...
I was in a lower gear of working out."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.